you do believe there would be an  agreement according to what second  foreign minister Lavrov is telling you  you yes I do believe in it and we are  aimed at achieving this result because  we believe it is very important to  defuse the situation but of the same  importance is the this following thing  all the countries in the region must not  feel that there is a moment coming for  them after which they can expect the  aggravation of the situation or some  threats emerging we can't let this  happen this feeling to emerge Russia is  aimed at developing good neighbourly  relations both with Iran and with all  the countries in the region